ha dong so is a good-looking man with a
strange ability one night while he is
strolling around the streets singing to
his self-composed song High hanging
Metals some organ traffickers kidnap him
and take him away then his body is
dissected bit by bit surprisingly dong
so can see everything happening despite
his being almost dead after a while the
surgeon takes out both of his eyes and
keeps them on a tray however the pupils
look as if they can still see the
surgeon notices this but before he can
act he receives a phone call while he is
away shockingly strange tentacle-like
things come out of dongso's wounds and
they start healing then he comes back to
life and slowly Rises up as the surgeon
watches in horror dong so grabs one of
his eyes and places it near his eye
socket lo and behold the strange
tentacle-like things pull the eye and
fix it in its place dongso tries
retrieving his other eye but at the same
time the surgeon summons for backup so
he jumps out the window and escapes next
time you're having a tough day just
remember pull yourself together
fast forward several months a strange
occurrence happens in the same city one
morning a beautiful sculpture of a woman
appears out of nowhere and this attracts
the attention of a lot of people as they
are curiously clicking pictures suddenly
Blood starts dripping from it in a
shocking turn of events it is revealed
that the sculpture isn't made up of clay
but it is instead an actual human molded
to look like a statue in no time the
police led by Chief Inspector Jang Wan
arrived there and take the body away
however even after hours of
Investigation all they find is a strange
mark on the body which looks like a
combination of the alphabet letters P
and L following this we are taken to
dong so who is now living an anonymous
life in the city he is wearing an eye
patch to hide his missing eye and seems
pretty shaken up by the incident one
night while he is practicing his songs
suddenly he feels a sharp pain in his
eye socket and experiences a vision in
it he sees a first person view of
someone looking at a picture of zodiac
signs on his computer one of the symbols
in the picture is the pl word that was
carved on the deceased girl from earlier
dong so also notices an array of
sketches around the person's table once
his strange vision is over he deduces
that he is seeing through his other eye
which has been transplanted to someone
else the next day as dong so is at his
workplace a junkyard he notices some
thugs harassing his old boss he tries to
make them stop but instead gets beaten
up then one of the thugs brings out a
knife and swings at a dong so hoping
that he will Dodge it but the ladder
doesn't move a bit because of this
dongso's ear gets sliced off and falls
to the ground the thugs are terrified at
the sight and they immediately run away
and after they are gone dongso uses his
mysterious ability to attach the ear
back to his body meanwhile the organ
traffickers are on the lookout for
dongsau as his Immortal body could be
worth millions Chief Inspector Zhang
also notices him near the crime scenes
and suspects that he is up to something
that night dongso tries to drown his
anxiety by immersing himself in music he
grabs a guitar and attempts to play the
song High hanging Metals how however
since it has been a while he is unable
to remember the courts so he goes to his
Anonymous YouTube channel and plays the
song in slow motion to grasp the chords
at the same time the guy from his vision
also plays the same song and as soon as
he does so his eyes start hurting dong
so also experiences excruciating pain in
his eye fed up with the weird
occurrences he decides to head to the
same place where he had been abducted
and look for his other eye unfortunately
when he arrives at the place one of the
organ traffickers immediately recognizes
him and calls for backup then a lengthy
Chase ensues dongso narrowly escapes and
attempts to flee but just then a girl
named Lisa approaches him she appears to
know about his condition and slices his
leg to check if the rumors are real to
her surprise dongso heals his wound in
the blink of an eye and escapes
following this we are shown the same man
from dongso's Visions going through his
Sketchbook shockingly the sketches are
of people who have been killed and
turned into statues this proves that the
person who has dog says other eye is the
murderer in the next scene we are
introduced to a woman named Lee rang who
is heading to work on a bus along the
way she gets bored and starts listening
to the high hanging Metals song on
YouTube which is apparently gone viral
after a while she reaches her workplace
and notices a large crowd outside they
are staring at a human statue which
turns out to be the latest murder in the
city after a while Lee is with her crush
and team leader Jin siop who happens to
be quiet and arrogant to break the
awkwardness Lee starts humming the high
hanging metal song and with this Jin
siop feels a sudden pain in his eye
dongso also experiences the same and he
starts getting a first person view
through the murderer's eye he sees the
woman Lee and her workplace this finally
reveals that the murderer is none other
than jinsiop himself we also get to know
that both of dongso's eyes recognize his
song so whenever it plays they start
reconnecting through telepathic means at
night dongso gets another Vision where
he gets a better look at jinsiop's
Sketchbook he sees the words corpse art
and decides to look it up on Google to
his horror he finds pictures of the
recent murders and finally realizes that
the person who has the other eye is in
fact the culprit the very next morning
he wastes no time and heads to the
location he saw in his Visions he
notices Lee and instantly recognizes her
so he approaches her and inquires about
the man she was with the previous day
but as expected Lee believes that he is
a creep and walks away now dongso has no
leads because he doesn't even know what
the murderer looks like so he decides to
find more clues about him he goes to a
horoscope specialist and asks her about
the cryptic PL sign she reveals that it
refers to the planet Pluto and is
generally regarded as a bad Omen dong so
then mentions the date of the recent two
murder cases and asks if there is any
connection between them the specialist
points out that they are definitely
connected and also explains that the
next similar date is the 25th of
December which is tomorrow this alarm's
dog so as he realizes he forgot to buy
Christmas presents and also that the
next murder is going to happen the next
day he wants to stop it from happening
but doesn't know where to start
meanwhile Lee arrives at ginsiops house
and makes love with him oblivious to the
fact that he is a cold-blooded killer
after they are done jinsiop heads to
take a shower while Lee scans through
the house she comes across his
Sketchbook and goes through it out of
curiosity Lee is taken aback when she
sees the gruesome sketches of the
recently murdered victims and comes to
know that her crush jinsiop is actually
the killer the following day it is the
25th of December and as dongso had
predicted a statute corpse is found in
an isolated field a huge crowd gathers
and among them are the organ traffickers
and inspector Jang unfortunately both
the parties notice dong so and start
chasing after him the organ traffickers
get to him first but in the nick of time
the mysterious girl from earlier Lisa
arrives and knocks them out she then
takes dongso to a safe place and
introduces herself properly apparently
she is a novelist who is currently
writing an article about the connects
connects are Supernatural humans like
dong so who have the ability to
regenerate their body parts hence making
them Immortal before departing the two
exchanged their numbers and promised to
meet soon on the other hand a scaredly
approaches one of her colleagues and
tells them about what she saw in
jinsiop's SketchBook later she meets
jinsiop and requests to speak in private
the two then head to the rooftop and Lee
confronts him for being a murderer she
explains that she saw all of his
sketches and his elaborate evil plans
her colleague is keeping an eye on them
from a corner but unfortunately his cell
phone rings and this blows his cover
alarmed jinsiop first knocksly out and
then goes after the colleague he is
about to push him off the edge of the
building but just then Lee's cell phone
starts ringing which has the high
hanging metal song as a ringtone this
hurts jinsiop and at the same time dong
so who is nearby gets a vision of the
rooftop unfortunately before he can
reach the place jinsiop Chucks the
colleague from the building and kills
him oh he also finishes off Lee to tie
up all the Loose Ends all this time the
song keeps playing and a terrified dong
so Witnesses the entire incident the
only clue he notices is the murderer's
coat despite this he Rush to the
building by dodging numerous security
checkpoints he then races to the roof
but doesn't find anyone apart from Lee's
lifeless body at this point the entire
building is swarming with cops and
panicked people because of the two
murderers despite this dongso risks it
all and decides to find the killer who
has his eye he heads downstairs and
starts searching through the department
where jinsiop Works to his luck he
suddenly notices a man with the same
code as the murderer and goes after him
soon dongso reaches the washroom and
traps jinsiop inside one of the toilet
stalls but unfortunately before he can
take a look at his face some security
Personnel arrive and take him away it
turns out that the officers tracked his
activities through cameras and are
suspecting him of being the murderer
dong so tries his best to explain that
the real murderer is still in the
washroom but no one listens to him
fortunately the novelist Lisa again
comes to his rescue and frees him in the
meantime jinsiop is left in utter
disbelief at how someone could have seen
him committing the murders he spends
hours thinking about it but doesn't come
to a conclusion but when he hears the
same song and experiences a sharp pain
in his eyes he finally realizes that his
transplanted eye is causing the problem
Whoever has the other eye can see
through him and experience everything
that he does ah the only way to fix this
is with a surgery at the ICU on the
other hand dongso takes Lisa home and
explains everything to her from scratch
he starts from his childhood where he
had fallen off a tree and broken his
limbs but miraculously every bone
repaired itself in seconds his friends
called him a monster and even his family
isolated themselves from him dong so
then explains about the night where he
was kidnapped by organ Harvesters he was
cut open and his eyes were taken out but
due to his powers he healed all the
wounds and regained Consciousness he
then put one of his eyes back and fled
the scene before the bad guys approached
him now he is having first-person
visions of the person who has his other
eye the person is none other than the
Most Wanted murderer in the city he
knows this because of the elaborate
sketches and the other plans he saw in
his Visions however the problem is that
he still hasn't seen them murderer's
face hearing all of this Lisa is taken
aback but nonetheless she decides to
help him she also gives him a pair of
sunglasses to keep him off the radar as
his iconic eye patch has become easily
recognizable at night the two go to a
department store to get some supplies
where dong so notices his wanted poster
on the wall alarmed he quickly races
outside and tries running away but at
the same time his eye starts hurting
then he gets a vision of the killer
watching his YouTube video this makes
dong so realize that he can only get
Visions when the killer listens to his
song High hanging Metals later that
night while he is brainstorming ideas to
tackle the situation he again gets a
vision this time he sees his own sketch
being drawn by the murderer it appears
as if jinsiop is trying to warn dong so
to stay away from his business however
in the process he accidentally shows his
next targets which happen to be three
school girls thongso is taken aback by
what he sees and he decides to find the
killer before any death occurs he knows
that the entire city is on the lookout
for him but at this point points he
doesn't care in the final scene as dong
so is out to find Clues he stumbles upon
a street musician who is playing his
song's cover for a moment he forgets all
of his worries and gets lost in the
beauty of the song that he himself
created what a narcissist however dong
so's happy moment is short-lived as he
once again gets a vision surprisingly in
it he sees himself twitching in pain
this means that the Killer is watching
him from nearby when dongso comes to his
senses and looks around he notices a
shadowy figure observing him from a
nearby car dong so screams and
immediately goes after him but at the
same time inspector Jang and his
colleagues arrive and arrest him the
episode ends as a devastated dong so is
taken away to the police station this
show kicks ass be sure to catch the
following episodes on series Recaps